[Music]
my name is nicole evans
i am from simi valley california and i
have osteogenesis imperfecta
it is a bone condition that causes
brittle bones in small stature
being a person with a disability it's
ingrained in you then you already have
to think ahead
i budget that into
[Music]
i'm auditioning for a network one hour
drama medical procedural show
it's a self tape audition i'm nervous
i've always been an actor i guess i was
always involved in the school plays
i liked the fun of it just getting to
play and
dress up then one thing led to another
and then once i graduated grad school
that's when i started pursuing acting
professionally
whenever i have an audition ryan always
runs lines with me
i try to be as word perfect as i can so
he catches me on that
we've talked about this and why ask why
but man it's hard to stop
let's do some surgery
i usually make him do it like 50 times
when i first started pursuing acting
professionally
i got worried about will i be able to
find work as an actor with a disability
but now that door is opening for me it's
really important
to see actors with disability on the
screen where
the role that they're playing has
nothing to do with their disability
there is a want and a need to see
authentic representation upon the screen
and behind the camera
and why ask why but man it's hard to
stop
let's do some surgery i entered in the
academy gold program
as a rudiment foundation intern i had
no idea what i was getting myself into
and it turned out to be this roller
coaster
of education and friendship and learning
about the entertainment institute for
our sound stage experience
we had a generic one-page scene
and it was so fun working with the
director
changing your wardrobe to match the
scene it was a really interesting
exercise that really kept you on your
toes and what was great about it is that
we filmed it back to back to back that
you just jumped in and did it
and that was a really good exercise as
an actor
i think the most important thing i
learned from
the academy gold program was how
important it is to know every side of
the industry
it's pretty incredible what it takes to
get a film
to the screen and it really makes you
appreciate all the work that goes into
it
i encourage any actor or artist or any
sort of filmmaker with a disability
to get involved in the academy gold
program it's
very inclusive and diverse and
representation absolutely matters
you